every movie is going to test someone
once twice after it's made so on the
frame what were one or two of those
moments where your backs were against
the wall and then you were definitely
going through with it but it was at a
moment where just it things didn't look
good hmm hmm most moments during the
frame i think would like that i think
it's funny because every time you get
into the shooting you know you prepare
and you prepare and you prepare and then
once you're actually in this shooting
process you just you know once that
starts you can't you know you're at a
point where you can't go back you know
and i remember there was about maybe a
third to half way through the film I
just remember saying that I remember
thinking oh we're already in this we
can't we can't turn around and we're so
exhausted and I think it's just I think
just getting through it as a whole I
mean it's such a monumental task and you
always hear phone makers say that make
any movies like war and it really is i
mean it's a we always say that if you're
having a really good time making a movie
you're probably not making a very good
movie because it's just too easy and but
that's I mean that's part of it and so I
think just just sustaining just staying
on your feet the whole time through and
just getting it done if you can just do
that and that's an amazing
accomplishment and of itself but as far
as like specific moments there was a few
i think we had so we did about 11 weeks
of filming on the frame it was 55 days
and there was a period and the very
midpoint of the shoot we had done three
weeks of night shoots and as you'll see
if you watch the movie there's like
tractor-trailer tractor trailer and car
caught our cop car chases not in the
budget but we pulled it off anyway and
staying up those three weeks and then
having just the stress of having those
trucks rented and it really was this you
look up down both sides of the tunnel
and you're right in the middle and you
have to make a decision Dewey
here and start walking backwards or do
we just keep going and the choice was
obviously like we have all these people
and resources and people around us and
you just keep moving and so it's just a
stand up and what put one foot in front
of the other everyday type of situation
but we made it can you give specifics of
what maybe occurred was it you know I
mean probably putting a credit card as a
deposit for these trucks and and you
know there's a damaged or whatever you
know you're liable so what was going on
just dumb faith I suppose wine dumb luck
faith um no it was she looked like a
janitor for I did have so many keys I
had the keys to three semi trucks
Winnebago like for picture cars it was
like that no transpo department of
course and so had we wrecked any one of
those things our lives would have been
over so not a little let alone shut down
in production but yeah I mean those are
the risks that you take we have a magnet
on a refrigerator that says leap and the
net will appear and that's all you can
think in a moment like that is I've just
got to throw myself off the roof here
and hopefully somebody catches me when I
fall and it worked out so you just kind
of have the I guess just we were really
lucky that we had a really really good
crew I mean I was the best crew that
we've ever worked with and and I was
that was sort of our net you know and
everybody just just kind of kept us
energized and just kept going even
though we you know as every film that
you make you just take on way too much
yourself and you always wish you had you
you hadn't done that but I mean our crew
was just constantly just kind of keeping
us energized and keeping us optimistic
and I you think that's that's mainly how
we got through it yeah when it's just
the look the the thrill I guess of
having gotten that far it's already so
hard to write a script raise money get
everybody there that's the last time to
sit down and fail you know and you have
to have to keep going and there was
there was truly never any option to quit
they're really like we need that never
that's never crossed our minds ever it's
just if there was a moment that was kind
of that like which direction do we go a
moment it was
probably in the middle of those night
shoots
you